hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well are we
responsible for the kinds of people that
we are for the good or bad moral
qualities that have become part of our
personality or excuse an older term and
become determinate 'iv of our an
expressive of our characters Aristotle
says yes we are indeed responsible for
the kinds of people we are what
qualities we have in moral terms you
also even go so far as to say in some
respects we're also responsible for our
physical state but it we'll get to that
in a moment so another way of asking
this is our virtue and vice moral
excellence moral defectiveness or
failure something that depends on us the
term that Aristotle actually uses here
is reminiscent of later authors because
he talks about what is f who mean
literally up to us or our business
within our control and you mean
something that we can see and say the
Stoics later on that excuse does it
depend for Aristotle on our choices and
our reactions the answer that he has is
yes there are course some exceptions he
will talk in book seven of the nikah
McCann
Thanks about brutality where a person
doesn't really have that capacity to
determine their character but that says
that's a different topic we have another
video coming out on that which you can
peruse and that your your will for the
most part unless we're talking about a
rather extraordinary circumstances we
have some responsibility for the people
that we become find ourselves to be and
then choose to change ourselves into so
Aristotle says a number of different
things here some of which I put up on
the board some of which I've just read
to you know read out of the text and
comment on the first thing that's really
interesting is he talks about freedom
what what is up to us he doesn't mean
freedom in some sort of absolutely
metaphysical sense and all don't be
overly concerned about what the
definition of freedom is here he's
talking a very commonsensical way when
it's up to us when it's our choice
whether we want to yeah when we are free
to act to do something literally
practices we are also free to not act
right so that seems like a truism but
it's something worth reminding ourselves
up because there's lots of people and
this is one of us the cats of promise
there's lots of people who want to take
credit for some of the things as being
up to them and then we go off the hook
when it's bad things that they're
involved in someone that really wasn't
up to me it wasn't my choice wasn't my
decision
Arizona says look if we're responsible
for doing the right things for engaging
in the right actions we're also
responsible when we don't do the things
that we know are right actions likewise
are also responsible when we do the
wrong actions or when we choose not to
do the wrong actions which would be a
good thing right not as good as doing
right actions at least not doing it
wrong actions if we are you might say in
for a penny in for a pound if you want
to take credit for the good you have to
also be willing to extend the credit for
other people to criticize you for the
pain app so what is the supply here
says it's when we can trace our actions
and our choices back to ourselves we've
got a video here on the voluntary and
the involuntary so what we're talking
about is the voluntary but also the
realm of the the mixed actions as well
and your subtle sense that we are
ourselves to some degree self moved
movers we are agents we can choose some
things at least for ourselves not with
you know total control over everything
obviously I and I'm a 45 year old man
right now as you see this video yeah I'm
not going to turn the clock back
although I can exercise or lose some
weight and start feeling a bit younger
but you know I have what I have and if I
want to change some relatively
well-established dispositions of myself
it's going to take quite a bit of work
but I did that some measure of choice
about that obviously as we get closer to
the end perhaps we have less actually
have less ability to make use of that
choice but we still have some so when we
increase things back to ourselves we can
hold ourselves responsible for it that
doesn't mean that we don't consider how
other people played into things for
example if I had bad examples from you
know people that I was raised by or my
teachers or things like that if I fell
in with a bad crowd as we say if I
belong to a culture that's sending me
the wrong messages that will make it
more difficult for me and I know people
this would sort of push the
responsibility off to some degree to
them we can also talk in terms of what
some people have called moral luck you
know none of that completely eliminates
human responsibility according to
Aristotle so another consideration that
he brings up that's very important he
talks about this in terms of the law
makers but we can also think about this
in terms of any sort of social function
where people are giving praise or
criticism or blame and a little to terms
for the same idea or awards and
wanted new people in fact give rewards
or punishments why do people give praise
or criticism it's because they are
making the assumption that people are in
fact morally responsible and they're
therefore are deserving of the good or
the bad in this case so you know these
are four things that we assumed to be
voluntary we may be mistaken about
whether something really is voluntary
and we may actually arrive yeah you know
a realization that some things that we
thought were completely voluntary really
aren't so much up to the person you know
for example our understanding of mental
disorders psychological problems hunger
you want to put it I don't want to get
anybody riled up and getting offended
about that that's their choice of course
our understanding of that is a bit
better than it used to be in the past
so you know for example somebody who
back in the 1960s oh I have a mind who
has just written off as being a bad kid
and a troublemaker it turned out was
bipolar and there is a genuine physical
disorder there the problem with brain
chemistry that can be remedied to a
certain degree by my regimes of
medication drop and have to change every
so often and also with other forms of
therapy the most successful of which
tend to incorporate something like
virtue ethics and habit modification in
their their worries so we can say that
perhaps you know praise and blame might
be wrongly given because we assume
something to be more voluntary than
goodness but Aristotle still wants to
say that look if somebody does have a
disorder unless it's a very severe
disorder they still have some degree of
decision-making capability maybe more
difficult for them but they can they can
choose what's going to become of them
particularly once they realize the
condition that they're in aerosol also
says that we can be responsible for the
ignorance which we end up in so not all
ignorance
us off the hook if we're the kind of
person who's typically negligent he says
like that's because you decided not to
put in the attention that was needed to
keep from being negligent it may have
turned into a character trait after a
while but you know if you don't exercise
the the you know activity painting
attention then you need to do you're not
going to suddenly become attentive no of
course you can perhaps take a pill that
will make you more attentive for a
certain time that's that's not really
changing your character us are changing
your brain chemistry in here the way
your things are gonna react and stop
taking the pill if you go back to being
what you are
you know if we're ignorant for our own
fault then we are responsible for them
he gives a lot of examples like this he
says you know if somebody is drunk you
can say well being drunk sort of gets
them off the hook but did somebody force
them to drink no you might say something
like well yeah they were going to the
track party and it was part of the
initiation thing everybody has to drink
drink drink they're playing a drinking
game I think it's still say to the
person well who the hell told you you
had to do that that was up to you you
weren't forced into it unless you know
perhaps somebody actually was held at
gunpoint and then it's a matter of
compulsion but in a lot of cases of
ignorance it's it's our own fault that
were ignorant to the to some degree he
says it may be objected and perhaps the
the person isn't the kind of person to
take the trouble well people are
responsible for having become careless
through living carelessly as they are
for becoming unjust or prolific yet if
they do wrong or pass their time and
drinking and dissipation people acquire
particular qualities like I have here
people acquire particular qualities by
acting consistently in certain ways so
when we behave in a certain way we're
not just deciding for that moment
we're also maturing that into the weight
of the balances that decide are we going
towards virtue or are we going towards
vice so he has a lot of good examples
here he says you know by the time that
our
character is fixed some people want to
say look you know the unjust person the
greedy person you know just to take one
example they don't really have control
over what they're doing because now has
become something like a sickness for
them it's it's something then they they
can't go against their desires are
screwed up and they're they're oriented
in the wrong ways Aristotle would say
yeah you're right just like when we
throw a stone after you've thrown the
stone you can't take it back or if you
shoot an arrow at somebody you can't
take it back but who told you to throw
the stone in the first place or shoot
the arrow you have a choice about that
so if we're unjust and we commit unjust
actions very easily and think that
that's the right thing to do that's
because along the way we made ourselves
on just Aristotle would say and he's not
diminishing other people's culpability
in it for sending us throwing messages
or deforming our character he says you
can't just become unadjusted I wish
induce Oh any any more than a sick man
can get well by wishing although it may
be the case that his illness is
voluntary in the sense of being due to
intemperate living and neglect with the
doctor's advice
Aristotle you know when it comes to
things like a lot of the diseases that
we encounter
for example stemming from lives of sins
he reliving in obesity Harris let's say
you have the possibility of getting up
off your butt and doing exercise we're
not eating thirds every night we're now
having midnight snacks of I don't know
polos watch down with with a you know a
sugary drink that's that's within your
capability and we you know in our
society were very conflicted about this
army and they were conflicted also an
ancient Greek society as well but here
Istanbul comes down on the side of you
know some degree of moral responsibility
he says that uh not only your vices are
the sole voluntary but in some cases
bodily defects nobody blames a person
for being born ugly that's that's not
their choice but we do stature
- that's due to neglecting exercising
care of a person
also with infirmities and mutilation
nobody would reproach but rather pity a
person who's blind from birth but you're
blind
there's no sense could you drink all the
time or you're blind because you went
out and got yourself a disease through
your own activities well then we might
blinding it for that and we'd still feel
sorry and we can still they don't make
exceptions but we can also say it's your
responsibility and then he goes on he
considers an interesting case he says
somebody maybe says all people seek what
seems to them good but they're not
responsible for it seeming good each
man's conception of his end is
determined by his character whatever
that may be so the idea here is well we
just have different temperaments and
some people are nice people and some
people are mean people some people are
greedy some people aren't you know much
more altruistic it's just the way people
happen to be I was born this way it's
how we how we often say it right and err
someone says look people can have
different temperaments some people may
be more prone to anger some people less
prone to anger I'm willing to grant you
all of that but we still have some stake
in the kinds of people that we become
and the evidence for this is partly that
those people still want to be praised
and rewarded and looked up to for when
they do things that are morally good
that come from their character they
really just don't want to be blamed and
criticized and you know punished or
incur any sort of other thing that's
negative because of the negative aspects
of their character he says if this
theory were true how will virtue be
voluntary and any more than vice if this
theory if we want to say that this
theory is true
quit rewarding everybody nobody gets a
gold star it's not that everybody gets a
gold star nobody gets a gold star there
are no more surprise that how we even do
it and Arizona says the good man with
man-mana life the view of their end is
determined in the same manner all of the
reactions of whatever sort of guided by
a reference to their end
as thus determined whether there's a
man's view of his end is not given by
nature but is partly due to himself or
whether his end is determined by nature
yet virtue is voluntary because a good
man's actions to gain is end their
voluntary in either case vice will be
just as much voluntary as virtue for the
good as the bad man I'm equally with the
good possesses spontaneity in his
actions even if not in a choice of an
end so the long and short of this is
we're not totally responsible in the
sense that you know we're to be blamed
for every single failing that we engage
in but we shouldn't try to get ourselves
off the hook either and if we realize
negative aspects of ourselves that we're
not particularly proud of we need to
take stock of those as being part of who
we are rather than it just as merely
attempting to shift the blame off to
society or genetics or pick whatever
other excuse of the day what happens to
him the long and short of it is if we're
responsible for the good parts of our
character were equally responsible for
the bad parts of our character and this
place is upon us something that may in
fact feel a little bit of a crushing
burden to some but it's also
extraordinarily extraordinarily
liberating it means that nobody unless
there is so so far gone that they can't
even understand what's being said is
indeed so far gone that they can't
change their character for the better